[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof
hello Walter hello Martin are you okay
I'm fine the world is in chaos but uh
it's a sign of the end right obviously
our eyes should go up for where our
Redemption draweth so let's open with a
word of Prayer our only father
thank you for all the blessings that you
give us Lord without you we can do
nothing that's why we ask that you
please come now in our midst and also
Enlighten our minds Enlighten the
viewers and help us in this discussion
this wonderful things that we can
discuss about you in Jesus name amen
Martin we're going to talk about last
day's time of the end latter days that
day
there's a lot of confusion as to what
these terms actually mean
and I believe we are living in the last
days we're living in the latter days and
I believe that that day is coming very
soon
we are definitely in the time of the end
yes
and we've had lots of activities of
light
we've had the DeVos period we've
discussed that then we had this terrible
earthquake with thousands upon thousands
dead and still trapped and
the world is in the chaos right yeah
you've got also the stirings of war or
you mean that balloon that spy balloon
of China yes yep these are all things to
raise tensions create chaos there's a
food crisis coming
everybody's warning that's it I don't
know whether people can hear the rain or
we're having floods here or roads are
being washed away
we are living in a very dramatic times
well that those dramatic times are
spoken of in the Bible and that's why
we've titled this because it's mentioned
there now we're not going to do the
signs of the times we've done that
everybody can read Matthew 24. and find
out you know what will happen in the
last days
but people are inclined to say
it's been like that for a long long time
yes so what makes this different yes so
we thought it might be a good idea to
look at what the Bible actually refers
to
when it talks about last day's time of
the end later days that day what are we
really talking about yes so that when
you read it you can put in context what
it's referring to yes it's important it
actually helped me the study helped me
as well to somewhere sometimes you can
read something but you don't put it
where it belongs you put it in the wrong
spot yes
and then of course we still have current
events that we have to talk about and
where the world is heading
we'll do that in the next one again Ryan
yeah because you the things we see now
the things that you send me and the
things that I we look at
that pendulum that's starting to swing
it's picking up momentum we are soon
going to have Draconian religious laws
yeah it's on the verge it's in every
most countries
there's not many countries that's going
to escape it no no I believe nobody's
going to escape it they're all going to
be there
so let's have a look at this subject and
see what we can glean
if you read your Bible you will see that
they are different eras you have the
anti-deluvian world
which was destroyed
by the flood
and eight people ate the number of
Christ
are those that escaped
and then you have the patriarchal period
and you had the period of the judges
then you had the period of the Kingdom
and the kingdoms would not come to an
end until the Messiah would come because
the Bible says that the scepter will not
depart from Judah until he the Messiah
comes and that was fulfilled to the
letter so hey anybody
can dispute
the biblical prophecies
is amazing true and then follows the
Christian era
and it's interesting that the Christian
area era has now been running for 2000
years
that's basically two Cosmic days if you
believe in the cosmic weak Theory
now all our Pioneers believed it as we
said before
and it's pretty strongly supported in
the spirit of Prophecy and I believe
it's biblical
so I'm very interested in that time
period because no matter which way you
cut it that time period is coming to an
end that's true well if I can digress
just a little bit quickly from here
I think you mentioned earlier
or previously
the time periods of the kings of of the
Pharaohs of Egypt used to be 12 000 and
10 000 years ago but after the
discoveries of archeology it's been
shown that they co-ruled so that time
periods came down
to under four and a half thousand years
three thousand people you see sir even
that brings it in
that the time period that the Bible is
giving us is much more accurate
well
the reformers believed it the Pioneers
believed it
the Bible says it I have no reason to
disbelieve it
and then you come to the time of the end
then you have a remnant
that brings a final message
there will be a shaking
which culminates in a loud cry and then
we go home
so that's basically the summary of the
timelines in the Bible right you have
the anti-diluvian world you have the
patriarchal period the kingdoms the
Christian era then you come to the time
of the end then you have a Remnant you
have a shaking you have a loud cry and
then it's going up that's basically the
timeline
and we have to determine where we are in
the Stream of time that's it now it's
important to put everything in the
correct period
right so let's look at the last days
if you do a search engine search
on the last days you will find uh eight
verses
eight matches
and basically it refers to the Christian
era so let's have a look of it because
it brings about a lot of confusion
in Genesis you have this text which says
and Jacob called unto his sons and said
Gather yourselves together that I may
tell you what shall befall you in the
last days
now many people believe this is the
final little period of time that we are
living in yes but it's much broader than
that and we have to understand that
because otherwise we're going to say as
many people say oh this has happened
before who says it's the last days
what does it mean when the Bible says
last days
there's another verse in Isaiah
and it shall come to pass them the last
days
that the mountain of the Lord's house
shall be established in the top of the
mountains and shall be exalted above the
hills and All Nations shall flow into it
this is an amazing prophecy
so when are the last days is it the last
period of time that we are living in now
no this is a reference to the Christian
era yes and we'll find out in a moment
why that is so
now the mountain of the Lord's house
that's the kingdom
and Jesus referred often to the kingdom
that the kingdom is with you now that's
it because it's the establishment of the
Christian era
and it's not referring to the final
setting up of the Kingdom which Sony
takes place after the Millennium correct
so this is when it will be established
when in the last days
and it will be a mighty power because it
will be established on top of the
mountains over and above all the
kingdoms right that's it it shall be
exalted above the hills that's Hebrew
parallelism yeah just saying the same
thing in the same way and All Nations
shall flow into it
now if we look at the history of the
world
which nations Rose above all other
nations in power in you name it
technology all of these things it's the
Christian nations
and in particular the Protestant Nations
yes they were the wealthiest Nations
they were the most powerful Nations the
United States for example
Etc it is absolutely a fulfillment of
Prophecy that the Christian era stands
out in history as a very powerful era
yes and All Nations
flow into it because Christianity is not
confined to Christian nations
in all other nations Christianity gained
a foothold even if it is under
persecution that's it
so this is a reference to the Christian
era here's another verse in Micah 4
verse 1 but in the last days
it shall come to pass that the mountain
of the house of the Lord shall be
established in the top of the mountains
and it shall be exalted above the hills
and people shall flow into it so Martin
isn't it amazing that Micah repeats the
prophecy of Isaiah almost word for word
right yeah
so this has to be carefully studied
now let's go to Acts chapter 2 verse 17.
it shall come to pass in the last days
says God I will pour out my spirit upon
All Flesh and your sons and daughters
shall prophesy and your young men shall
see visions and your old men shall dream
dreams
now many believe that this only refers
to the last period of time in Earth's
history so that this will be a very
special event that will take place no
it refers to the last days so it refers
to an entire period so let's go a little
bit further second Timothy 3 verse 1
this know also that in the last days
perilous times shall come
does that refer only to the last days no
to the entire Christian era exactly it
was persecution from the disciples day
one it was persecution so that's why
people say but this has always been
exactly you and if but once you
understand this now that the last days
stretch right up to then then you can't
say oh it's already been because yes of
course because it's still going so we
have to separate what happens in the
very last period from what happened here
James 5 3 your gold and silver is
cankered and the rest of them shall be
witness against you and shall eat your
flesh as it were fire ye have heaped
Treasures together for the last days
period
knowing this first that there shall come
in the last days scoffers walking after
their own lusts
now Martin
these scoffers are only coming in our
time or were they there from the
beginning they're there from the
beginning but you see most include
myself also thought okay this will be in
the end and these coffers are the ones
that telling you oh it's happened before
so when Jesus says that the kingdom is
amongst you
and that the kingdom is near and that
the kingdom has arrived it's talking
about the Christian era the entire
Christian era and there were scoffers
and there were gainsayers I mean look at
all the gnostics how they manipulated
the word with their alexandrian
manuscripts and all the nonsense
denigrating Jesus and bringing him down
these are scoffers yes and they have
existed throughout the entire Christian
era look at those that rejected Jesus
didn't they scoff oh you saved others
himself he cannot save get down from the
cross there didn't they scoff exactly
so the scoffing
is about the Christian era the scoffing
is about Jesus Christ yes it's against
the word of God
manifested
in the flesh
so the entire war is against Jesus
Christ
it will
increase
at the maybe the last portion of the
last days correct but just grab that top
book there
this book says the great controversy yes
between Christ and Satan that's it
this is the history
of the last days that the entire book it
starts with the destruction of Jerusalem
that's right where the Christian era
started taking place this is a beautiful
old volume
of that book so these are the last days
Martin exactly and we need to study them
to understand them in their fullness it
includes the entire history of the first
church the early Christian Church the
right through to the falling away to the
Reformation and eventually to the
remnant that has to restore all things
bringer Three Angels messages and take
us to the last day exactly
so if we can we advertise this is an
important book get it and read it yes
it has a place of honor then yeah
all right so once we've established that
the last days refer to the Christian era
then we can look at some parallel
references
we also have the term last time
which is exactly the same just another
way of saying it
it also refers to the Christian era and
there are three
verses and four matches for this term
the last time
the one you find in one Peter one was
five
were kept by the power of God through
faith unto salvation ready to be
revealed in the last time
the whole era the whole Christian era 1
John 2 18 Little Children it is the last
time
and as you have heard that Antichrist
shall come even now are there many
antichrists whereby we know that it is
the last time exactly already living in
it living in it
so Antichrist was going to come Simon
magus
was one that decided that he wanted to
buy his way into power
and Peter rebuked him and he became the
Sorcerer of Nero yeah
and that's probably the Simon that they
call the Petra the Simon Peter yes the
Pope the first pope of the Catholic
Church the Forerunner for that and it
was going to come so it is paganism and
sorcery masquerading as Christianity
all right so now we established that the
last time and the last days refers to
exactly the same period
or Jude 118 how that they told you there
should be mockers in the last time
who should walk after their own ungodly
lusts
didn't Paul warn about them yes yes and
he won those early churches that they
have to beware of these people so this
is not only a reference to the very last
portion of human history it's the entire
Christian era now let's just think about
that
if the last days
and the last time refers to the entire
Christian era which has been going for 2
000 years now
is there anything else that comes after
the Christian era no no no era the
kingdom no error so can we expect Martin
a new religion to come that will
supersede Christianity no no so Martin
if the Christian era
is the very final era
which is relevant to scripture
then surely there cannot be any other
era that follows it because this is the
last one correct the last era the last
time
so at the risk of being contentious
if a new religion arises after the
Christian era has already commenced
let's say like Islam for example that
negates the Divinity of Christ
whereas the Divinity of Christ and the
Redemption through Christ was the bone
of contention
then does that not fall into the
category of the scoffers yes they're
directly in there it's not a new era I
cannot begin a new year the Bible
doesn't talk about a new era so there
cannot be a new era that negates the
Christian era correct it has to be
scoffers yeah
all right Martin so that's very
interesting so the mountain of the Lord
this Kingdom that is being set up that
works like yeast
that permeates through all nations
all nations are touched by Christianity
some Nations Rebel more violently than
others against it but eventually all
nations are in Rebellion to bible-based
Christianity right yeah
okay so that sets the stage the
Battleground is the last days
the last time period
so anything that falls outside of that
definition is spurious yes
and we'll lead to scoffing
so as we have seen there's more than one
term describing the Christian era
so you have to look at the context you
have to study it let's look at some
other terminology in the Bible
that is very descriptive you have the
term last day
and there are eight verses and eight
matches for the term last day
and it normally refers to the day of the
Lord's coming
so
Nehemiah 8 18
also Day by Day from the first day unto
the last day he read in the book of the
law and they kept the feast seven days
Etc so obviously this is just a
reference to a time period that came to
an end yeah so you're gonna have last
day and you don't have to read anything
in it
it is the last day of the week etc etc
but then you have this one here in John
6 39 and this is the Father's will which
has sent me
that of all which he has given me I
should lose nothing but should raise it
up again at the last day
that's the last day
of History prior to the Millennium yes
John 6 40 and this is the will of him
that sent me that everyone which sees
the son and believeth on him may have
everlasting life and I will raise him up
at the last day that's a very specific
day the very final day the Advent the
second Advent that's the second Advent
John 6 44 no man can come to me except
the Father which has sent me draw him
and I will raise him up at the last day
so they're all referring to the exact
same time period a very important time
because that's the end of all things
prior to the Millennium yeah that's
actually the end of time that's the
second coming of Christ
and then John 6 54 whoever eateth My
Flesh and drinketh my blood has eternal
life and I will raise him up at the last
day
or John 7 37 in the last day that great
day of the feast Jesus stood and cried
there again it's just an historic day
Martha said unto him I know that he
shall rise again in the resurrection at
the last day we must be very circumspect
when we study these things yes you have
to
I enjoy this study because it puts
everything in context you can't read out
of context and then apply something that
you read there and say oh but this is
the last day if it doesn't harmonize
with the rest of the script correct you
have to study the wording and you have
to say to yourself what does this refer
to
he that rejecteth me and receiveth not
my words hath one that judges him the
word that I have spoken the same shall
judge him in the last day
because you are the part of the
resurrection of the righteous or you're
not right yeah and you're either amongst
the living righteous or you are not
so that's a very specific term there's
another term that is used
also for that same event
and that is for that day
that's also the day of the Lord's coming
there are two matches for this Jeremiah
30 verse 7 alas for that day is great
so that none is like it it is even the
time of Jacob's trouble but he shall be
saved out of it
or second Thessalonians 2 3 let no man
deceive you by any means for that day
shall not come except there come a
falling away first and that man of sin
be revealed the Son of Perdition so that
day that final day of Christ's coming
will not come until these events have
taken place
all right so that very um this is not
very hard to understand no it's very
simple to understand
then you can do a little bit more
complicated one the time of the end when
is that that takes a little bit more
study when does the time of the end
start
so Martin we've seen that the last days
is the entire Christian era two thousand
years with all the calamities and dramas
and wars and dissensions against
Christianity and against Jesus Christ
the principal figure in the entire era
and I would go so far as to say that
more blood has been shed
around that name
than any other name in human history
true it has to
and it's been a bloody history yeah for
2 000 years
and that day
when it comes we'll put an end to it the
second coming
there will be a slight rising and an
attempt to take the city after the
Millennium but the redeemed will have
been redeemed and the lust will have
been lost at that day
now when is the time of the end let's
study it
Daniel 8 17. so he came near Where I
Stood and when he came I was afraid and
fell upon my face but he said unto me
understand o son of man
for at the time of the end
shall be the vision
time of the end so there's a specific
vision of Daniel 8. and it concerns the
time of the end when does the time of
the end start we need to know
Daniel 11 35
and some of them of understanding shall
fall to try them to purge and to make
them white even to the time of the end
because it is yet for a time appointed
so there's a specific time period
which the Bible calls the time of the
end to make sure that you don't confuse
it with the Christian era it says it is
for an appointed time yes it's for an
appointed time
and that day will not come until there's
been a falling away but when exactly
does the time of the end start we need
to pinpoint it
Daniel 11 40 and at the time of the end
shall the King of the South push at him
and the King of the North shall come
against him like a whirlwind with
chariots with Horsemen with many ships
and he shall enter the countries and
shall overflow and pass over now we've
discussed this one in great detail in
another what's a Prof series
but at this time period time of the end
you will have this battle between the
King of the South and the King of the
North I mean we're talking about it all
the time the whole time
so we must be living in that time right
yes we are and when does the time start
and when does it end well obviously it
ends with that day that day yes so we
are in it correct we need to understand
where we are standing in the Stream of
time yes because biblically otherwise
like we've mentioned before then
otherwise you can say oh but this has
happened before correct
all right now let's get to the
kinety-gritty of when does this time
period start Daniel 12 4.
but thou Daniel shut up the words and
sealed the book even to the time of the
end
many shall run to and fro and knowledge
shall be increased all right so when
will you start understanding the
prophecy of the 2300 days in the time of
the end when the UN seal the book all
right so when does it exactly start now
that prophecy you can get to a date
and you can argue whatever way you like
but it ends in 1844 because it gives you
a starting date the issuing of the
decree to restore and rebuild Jerusalem
and to
and then it gives you the Messiah and
then it gives you the date because 2 300
ends in 1844 whether we like it or not
we've discussed that many times
when will we start to unravel this thing
and start understanding it at the time
of the end yes
yes okay
so if we can put it just another way
to know that the 2 300 year
ends at 1844 the studying should be have
done be um have been done just a little
bit before which is the start of the end
time of the end time then correct let's
have a look at it Daniel 12 5. then I
Daniel looked and behold there stood
other two the one on this side of the
bank of the river
and the other on that side of the bank
of the river that's a very fascinating
prophecy you know so Envision he sees to
Heavenly beings
one on the one side one on the other
side
and there is another one over and above
it all right the one controlling
everything is Jesus Christ himself and
two Mighty Angels standing on either
side of the river that's one way to look
at it
now what does he actually see he sees
them clothed in linen so they are
righteous
and they're on either side of the river
the river of course is the Euphrates and
the Euphrates represents the peoples the
Nations the multitudes that constitute
the power of Babylon
but that river is very controlled
because there's one on the left and one
on the right
and there is the overall one controlling
it all
that river is actually under control
even though it is in flood and seems to
be taking the whole world captive
so let's look at verse six Daniel 12 6
and 1 said to the man clothed in linen
which was upon the waters of the river
how long shall it be to the end of these
wonders
and I heard the man clothed in linen
which was upon the waters of the river
so this is Christ himself speaking
when he held up his right hand and his
left hand unto heaven and swear by him
that liveth forever that it shall be for
a Time
times and a half
and when he shall have accomplished to
scatter the power of the Holy people all
these things shall be finished so it
starts after the time times and a half
that's the 1260 day period yes that's
the time period of papal Supremacy
that's it which ends in 1798. exactly so
the time of the end begins in 1798.
God's people
were scattered yes obviously Martin if
they were scattered
mustn't they be gathered again yes
so that must be the task of the remnant
correct okay so the time of the end
refers to the time period from 1798
after the time times and half a Time
prophecy
until that day nice
so we are living in the time of the end
yes well that makes clear that the
1948 Gathering of the state of Israel
has nothing to do with this no because
this comes after 1798 that's when the
papacy received the Mortal wound
so when that falling away should come
and this power would rule for
1260 years then at the time of the end
the King of the South secularism will
push against him apparently because he
seemed to have a mortal wound he didn't
really have one he just went underground
because of you know protestantism had
put him in a bad light
and the King of the South is really
controlled by the same Powers because
they're sitting at one table
and in this terrible time period the
time of the end the remnant has to come
together to bring the final Gathering to
fruition and to bring the final message
of warning
Daniel 12 9 and he said go thy way for
the words are closed that's the 2 300
day prophecy
sealed till the time of the end so the
unraveling and the understanding would
start in
1798 time of the end we are living in it
well it also brings that portion makes
it shows you how important it is to not
say that the book is still sealed so you
cannot
unravel Revelation because a lot of
churches say Okay nobody's a sealed book
it's not the Book of Revelation that is
it's a tiny portion of the prophecy of
death of Daniel exactly
so just to sum up again when the Bible
talks about the latter days it's not
talking about the time of the end no
it's talking about the Christian era so
this term latter days
is used 11 times in the Bible in the
King James version here's an example and
now behold I go unto my people come
therefore and I will advertise the what
this people shall do to thy people in
the latter days
here Moses is referring to the Christian
era the latter days
what will happen
in the latter days what will happen in
the Christian era there will be terrible
persecution
the catacombs all of the terrible
persecutions throughout the Protestant
era the millions and millions that were
slaughtered that's what the prophecy is
about not about the final little moments
of Earth history only no
or due to autonomy 4 30 when their art
in Tribulation and all these things are
come upon thee even in the latter days
if thou turn to the Lord thy God and
shall be obedient unto his voice
Deuteronomy 31 29 for I know that after
my death ye will utterly corrupt
yourselves and turn aside from the way
which I have commanded you and evil will
befall you in the latter days because
you will do evil in the sight of the
Lord to provoke him to anger through the
works of your hands button this is the
rejection of Christianity yes this is
the direction of Christ and it led up to
the destruction of Jerusalem correct
can you see how this starts making sense
Jeremiah 23 20 and the anger of the Lord
shall not return until ye have executed
until he have performed the thoughts of
his heart in the latter days ye shall
consider it perfectly
so you either accept Jesus Christ as the
Fulfillment of your types and shadows or
you reject them yeah that's it
Jeremiah 30 24 and the fierce anger of
the Lord shall not return until he have
done it and until he have performed the
intent of his heart in the latter days
ye shall consider it so basically
Jeremiah repeats what he said before
reference to the Christian era
and when the Jewish economy
rejected Jesus
then they're no longer in any future
time qualified to be part of the serum
no because that Christian area stretches
to their day and the mountain of the
Lord shall be above all the nations and
many will press in they have an
opportunity to press in
but not as a national that that's it so
that's so important no Nation will be
upheld as this is the nation of God
correct it cannot in the Christian era
that cannot happen no it is a universal
decision that has to be made for or
against Christ yes and if you accept
Christ you accept this government and if
you accept his government you accept his
law that's it
or Jeremiah 48 47 yet will I bring again
the Captivity of Moab in the latter days
says the Lord thus far is the Judgment
of Moab
so the descendants of these Pagan
Nations
they will have the opportunity in the
latter days to come back in yes or to
reject it that's their choice the whole
world so this is Christian era
Jeremiah 49 39 but it shall come to pass
in the latter days that I will bring
again the Captivity of Elam says the
Lord now it starts making sense he's
Gathering his people
in the sense of the Holy Spirit
convicting them that Jesus is the
Messiah he's Gathering them out of all
the heathenations even false
Christianity he's pulling them out of
gathering them in the Christian era
right so the war is Raging within
Christianity so anything modern
in this era that opposes Christianity is
not part of the Kingdom no
so that puts a whole different spin on
the ball any religious system that
arises
that is contrary
to Christianity whether it be the New
Age movement whether it be Islam whether
it be whatever
it doesn't fall into this Kingdom
category
Ezekiel says and thou shalt come up
against my people of Israel as a cloud
to cover the land it shall be in the
latter days and I will bring thee
against my land that the Heathen may
know me when I shall be Sanctified in
thee Oh Gog Before Their Eyes again this
is the battle the choice between
Christianity or not and you can you can
assign Gog to whatever you want Russia
or whatever you want the fact of the
matter is everybody on this Earth gets
an opportunity to make a choice yes
Daniel
but there is a God in heaven that
reveals secrets and makes known to King
Nebuchadnezzar what shall be in the
latter days
thy dream and the visions of thy Head
Upon thy bed are these
now what was he rebelling against he was
rebelling against the fact that his
kingdom would come to an end yeah yeah
so when with this Kingdom be set up that
people will push into Christian era
[Music]
so this is nothing to do with the very
final events
of course they are also in that Prophecy
in the ten toes that will be destroyed
on that day which is the last the last
day the rock that comes loose
so in Daniel 10 14 now I'm come to make
thee understand what shall befall thy
people in the latter days
for yet the vision is for many days
so Martin here he is referring to God's
people the Jewish Nation the tribes
Etc
what will happen to them in the latter
days they will have to make a decision
for or against the Messiah great so this
is the Christian era when Jesus was
there they had a decision to make
see if the Prophecies of if they had to
show if they are going to accept that
the prophecy showed that this is a
messiah and by rejecting him
they fall outside of the Christian era
they fall outside the last Kingdom
battle on this Earth so that gets rid of
the entire
Israel Vision exactly and uh negates it
that just shows you exactly that there
can be no Nation
that rejects Christ that can be a nation
in the Christian era again for God
correct and there are some like even
within our own country that believe
that a certain group in this country
will again be the people of God no no no
we are now in the anti-type it is a
universal decision out of all the even
Nations people will be pressing into
this Kingdom or they will be rejected
yes they will become part of this
spiritual Israel yes
oh Isaiah 3 verse 5 after which shall
the children of Israel return and seek
the Lord their God and David their King
and shall fear the lord and his goodness
in the latter days referring to the
Christian era David is used as a type of
Christ that's it so this verse
specifically shows you there will not be
a literal return of Israel no
you either accept Christianity or you
don't any religion let's repeat it again
that rejects Christ or makes him less
than he is does not form part of this
Christian era Kingdom
and then you have the term latter times
1 Timothy 4 1 now the spirit speaks
expressly that in the latter times
some shall depart from the faith giving
heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of devils the entire
Christian era that's it all right
then of course we have that day
now this is such a big deal in the Bible
we find this in 219 verses and there are
226 matches in other words in some
verses it appears more than once
so imagine this term that day mostly
it refers to the final day the second
coming of Christ but it can refer to a
specific day in history that something
happened
so you have to from the context
determine what does it mean so that day
largely refers to the coming of Christ
so for example in Genesis 33 16 so Esau
returned that day on his way unto sail
so it's just a historic record of a
thing that happened on a particular day
nothing to do with the second coming
Exodus 8 22 and I will sever in that day
the land of Goshen in which my people
dwell that no swarms of flies shall be
there
to the end that thou must know it that I
am the Lord in the midst of the earth
that also refers to a specific day in
history
during the plagues where God made a
difference between Israel and Egyptians
then you have Leviticus 1630.
for on that day shall the priest make an
atonement for you to cleanse you that
you may be clean from all your sins
before the Lord so that's also a
specific day referring to a specific day
in the feasts
numbers 11 32 and the people stood up
all that day and all that night
obviously we're just talking about a
historical direction we don't have to
just have to show that it's quite
logical to see which day is being spoken
about yes just to show that there are
verses that don't deal
specifically with the second coming of
Christ when it comes to this term
but most of them actually referred to
that day so the second coming of Christ
is an incredibly important feature in
the Bible with many many verses
referring to it so let's have a look at
some of them Isaiah 27 12. and it shall
come to pass in that day that the Lord
shall beat off from the channel of the
river unto the stream of Egypt and you
shall be gathered one by one O ye
children of Israel
that refers to the coming of Christ yes
and once again he will be gathered yes
once again not literal it's all the
children that accept Jesus
coming out
Isaiah 27 13 and shall come to pass in
that day that the great trumpet shall be
blown and they shall come which were
ready to perish in the land of Assyria
and the outcasts in the land of Egypt
and shall Worship the Lord in the Holy
Mountain at Jerusalem
this is anti-typical Jerusalem God's
people
Isaiah 28 5 in that day shall the Lord
of hosts be a Crown of Glory and for a
diadem of beauty unto the residue of his
people that's the remnant that remains
at the second coming of Christ
Isaiah 29 18 and in that day shall the
deaf hear the words of the book and the
eyes of the blind shall see out of
obscurity and out of Darkness
that's the final event the second coming
of Christ yes that's actually a hopeful
prophecy there
or verse 23 and Isaiah 30 then shall he
give the reign of thy seed and thou
shalt sow the ground with all and bread
of the increase of the earth and that
shall be fat and plenteous in that day
shall thy cattle feed in large pastures
this refers to me also it's it's hopeful
it's this is the new Earth
after that we've uh coming together
always like Isaiah 27 says and uh going
to that Holy Mountain the New Jerusalem
you're living in the country you've got
all these wonderful things in the new
Earth so that day is a day of great
promise and of Great Tribulation
depending on what side of of the choice
you are
Isaiah 31 verse 7 for in that day every
man shall Cast Away his idols of silver
and his idols of gold which your hands
have made unto you for a sin
now this can refer to that the final day
but it can also refer to the day when
you make your decision to follow Christ
that's very very um applicable then you
throw away your Idols every Earthly
thing
yes therefore my people shall know my
name therefore they shall know in that
day that I am he that does speak behold
it is I so that day has a number of
connotations it can be the day of your
choice it can be the day when this
tribulous world comes to an end it can
be the second coming so you have to read
the context
Jeremiah 30 7 the last for that day is
great so that none is like it it is even
the time of Jacob's troubles but he
shall be saved out of it this obviously
refers to the second coming
well Jeremiah 30 verse 8 and it shall
come to pass in that day says the Lord
of hosts that I will break his yoke from
off thy neck and will burst thy bonds
and strangers shall no more serve
themselves of him
so this is the final Reckoning with
Babylon
is next I'll be broken and it will be
the and he will be cast into the lack of
Fire
especially it shows also this part of
Jacob's trouble
which is part of the another period just
before that day
so Martin here's a whole list of verses
Isaiah Joel Zephaniah and Matthew we're
moving towards the New Testament we
don't have to read them all
suffice to say is that you have to glean
from the verse itself what it actually
refers to
so let's take Zephaniah 1 verse 10 and
it will come to pass in that day says
the Lord that there shall be a noise of
a cry from the fish gate and a howling
from the second and the great crashing
from the hills obviously referring to
the final day of the Lord's coming out
it'll be a day of Wrath the day of
trouble a day of distress Zephaniah
referring to the day of the Lord's
coming Matthew 7 22 many will say to me
in that day Lord Lord referring to what
this day of the Lord's come here so most
of these verses refer to that period
Matthew 24 36 but of that day and hour
knoweth no man no not the angels of
heaven but my father only so that refers
to the second coming it's not going to
the details of that verse we did that
under number eight and nine and nine
people can look there at number eight
and nine of WhatsApp Prof
look Rejoice ye in that day and leap for
Joy for behold your reward is great in
the heaven for in the like manner did
their fathers unto the prophets
referring to the second coming
or 17 31 in Luke in that day he which
shall be upon the house stop and his
stuff in the house let him not come down
to take it and he that is in the field
that him likewise not return back
button we have many many verses of this
nature and we don't have to go into them
all let's just do second Timothy 4 verse
8.
wherefore there's laid up for me a crown
of righteousness which the Lord the
righteous judge shall give me at that
day
and not to me only but unto all them
also that love his appearing
so these verses refer largely to the
second coming or to a specific event
so now we have a little bit of a summary
the time of the end from 1798
last days the entire Christian era that
day the coming of Christ okay so just
want to also say in that Christian era
the other ones that you mentioned have
got the remnant that came just after the
time of the end 1798. so you have to
look for the rise of the remnant
after the time of the end which is after
and it has very specific
characteristics yes
it arises historically after 1798.
it keeps the Commandment yes it has The
Testament yes that's very important it
reaches the Three Angels messages and it
remains until the coming of Christ
there's nothing afterwards until that
day
all right so the spirit of Prophecy
employs the term last days
three thousand six hundred and eight
times and the term last times 45 times
so how important is it that we study
this concept
so let's have a look at some of these
statements because they're quite
enlightening in the revelation of
portrait the Deep things of God the very
name given to its inspired Pages the
revelation
contradicts the statement that this is a
sealed book a revelation is something
revealed the Lord himself revealed to
his servants the Mysteries contained in
this book and the designs that they
shall be open to the study of all
its truths are addressed to those living
in the last days of this Earth's history
now Martin
did John write the Revelation yes
so nobody was to study it until the last
moments of time right no obviously it
had to be studied throughout the
Christian era so it's important it's not
a sealed book it's not a sealed book now
the next thing
did the reformers make use of the
Revelation yes yes the Martin Luther
they had to they had to right so it
refers to the Christian era
and this this resolves a lot of
confusion
the Lord himself revealed to his
servants the Mysteries contained in this
book and he designs that they shall be
open to the study of all the truths are
addressed to those living in the last
days of Earth's history as well as to
those living in the days of John so it's
the entire Christian era
some of the scenes depicted in this
prophecy are in the past some are now
taking place some bring to view the
clothes of the great conflict between
the powers of darkness and the prince of
heaven and some reveal the triumphs and
joys of the redeemed in the earth made
new so Martin
clearly it refers to the entire
Christian era and not just to the time
period when the remnant is active now
Martin the term last days as we have
seen refers to the entire Christian era
does that include the period of the
remnant and in the last
little portion of that era it includes
that it includes the time of trouble it
includes all of that all of it up until
the last day so everything that has to
do with the last days is Christian era
and depending where you are in the
Stream of time you can determine what
portion of this era you are in yes so
when we're talking about the time of the
end we know that's the final portion of
the 1798 but the war is still about the
same thing it's about accepting Jesus as
the Messiah and accepting his kingdom
which means accepting his rules that's
it all right so let's take a look at
this quote from Christ in his Sanctuary
looking down to the last days the same
infinite power declares concerning those
who received not the love of the truth
that they might be saved love of the
truth
that means they accept the word they
accept Jesus Christ as the Messiah and
they accept obedience to the
Commandments that's it so the last days
has to include from the days of the
disciples in Christ up until now
for this cause God shall send them
strong delusion that they should believe
a lie
that there may all be damned you believe
not the truth but had pleasure in
unrighteousness
2 Thessalonians 2 10 to 12. that's
referring to the falling away
and if they don't want righteousness
then they don't want the righteousness
of Christ and the righteousness is bound
up with his law
as they reject the teachings of his word
god withdraws his spirit and leaves them
to the deceptions which they love
let that therefore abide in you which
you have heard from the beginning if
that which ye have heard from the
beginning shall remain in you ye also
shall continue in the Sun and in the
father
so Martin when it says here from the
beginning
actually it refers to the entire history
of humanity correct because they also
heard the gospel in type it's the angel
says the Everlasting gospel it's an
everlasting gospel
and what has to remain in you your
understanding that there is the Messiah
that would come to save you
and it is bound up in the Divinity of
that Messiah because without Divinity he
cannot save you because he wouldn't have
life within himself
so let that therefore abide in you which
you have heard from the beginning of
that which you have heard from the
beginning shall remain in you ye also
shall continue in the Sun and in the
father
what is the message we are to receive in
practice for this is the message that
you heard from the beginning that you
should love one another
not as Cain who was of the wicked one
and slew his brother and wherefore
through him
because his own Works were evil and his
brother's righteous
that spirit
reigned from the very beginning and it
will rain till the very end and those
who hate God's law will rise up against
those that love God's law and will tend
to destroy them just like Cain destroyed
Abel with a difference God will
intervene at the end and prevent the
anti-typical cane from destroying the
anti-typical able
so this cruel spirit will be manifested
to those who Advocate the principles of
Christ
but let not the spirit discourage those
who have the truth for these last times
the last times is the Christian era yes
if you accepted Jesus Christ and you
were thrown to the lions in the in the
Roman Colosseum it's exactly the same
conflict that you will have at the End
of Time correct and this is just so
important because a lot of people will
we we've spoken about it want to put the
um things that the prophet is saying
into an era before we we live in now yes
and thereby negate the era we are living
in now so when we read the spirit of
Prophecy
it's still pertaining to today and it
will pertain right up until that day
it's like that book The Great
controversy
it spans the entire Christian era
and the final portion of that Christian
era is summarized in the book Last Day
Events yeah so this is something that
people can study and see where we are
heading because it is at the door
yeah and Martin I hope that we've laid
some groundwork
to show that after the Christian era
there's nothing
except that day yeah the coming of
Christ
and where are we we are living in the
time of the end that's it and in this
time of the end there are certain events
which will take place and they're
summarized in Last Day Events we are
living in the time of the remnant and
the remnant as the Bible and spirit of
Prophecy to help us through to the last
day now Martin
we are told in the great controversy and
in Last Day Events exactly how this will
take place
there will be persecution of those who
keep the Commandments and hold to the
testimony of Jesus
and the persecution will come
from those opposed to the Commandments
and largely from apostate Christianity
yes those who think they'll do they do
in God's will actually
currently as we are sitting here
the King of the South
is still holding the scepter but his
power is waning and very soon the
scepter will be handed over to his
so-called antithesis
all the Babylonian religions
led by the papacy
and the false prophet yes and in harmony
they will confront those who keep the
Commandments and hold to the testimony
and that pendulum from King of the South
philosophy secularism
two King of the North philosophy
religious legislation to enforce a
particular Dogma that is contrary to the
will of God and that will come into
opposition to those who keep the
Commandments and alter the testimony
that time is right before us and we'll
talk about that next time great thanks
let's close
Heavenly Father
we have looked at this conflict
and the conflict revolves around one
individual
Jesus Christ
help us to make the right decision
to accept the righteousness of Christ
and adhere to the principles of the only
true Messiah
who has kept his father's Commandments
and asks us to do the same is my prayer
in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you